[Música]
y en directo a nos vamos a estar nueva
york porque el expresidente de donald
trump se acogió a la quinta enmienda de
la constitución estadounidense para
evitar responder las preguntas de la
fiscal general del estado que investiga
sus negocios en la gran manzana ahí está
nuestra corresponsal mamen salame muy
buenas noches cuéntenos qué más
información tenemos de lo que ocurrió en
la oficina de la fiscalía
si han sido cuatro horas en las que la
fiscal general de nueva york ha hecho
muchas preguntas pero ha sido rápida la
respuesta a donald trump se ha acogido
en todo momento a la quinta enmienda a
ese derecho a no declarar para no
autoinculparse ha dicho más tarde el
abogado del expresidente que donald
trump solamente ha contestado al
principio de la sesión cuando se le ha
preguntado sobre su nombre y que ha
leído un escrito en el que decía que
esto es simplemente una continuación de
esa caza de brujas que está viendo el
país y que la fiscal general del estado
de nueva york letizia james había
comenzado una campaña abierta con el fin
de destruirlo el abogado del
exmandatario ha dicho también que la
fiscal de nueva york la fiscal general
de nueva york no sabía que donald trump
se iba a a la quinta enmienda ha
sido una decisión de último minuto de
hecho el ex presidente quería testificar
y han sido sus abogados los que han
tenido que convencerle de que no lo
hiciera
ahora amén qué tipo de causa se está
investigando y qué otras citas legales
le esperan al emporio throne de esta
semana
si se trata de una causa civil en la que
se está investigando si donald trump
tergiversó el valor de sus activos son
más poderosos como pueden ser los campos
de golf o los edificios para conseguir
beneficios económicos como deducciones
fiscales o préstamos y si lo hizo
engañando a los prestamistas y por
supuesto a las autoridades fiscales de
nueva york en esta causa civil que ya
está a punto de terminar han declarado
también los dos hijos mayores de donald
trump y el ex presidente ha intentado en
todo momento retrasar su declaración la
última vez que se retrasó fue
precisamente cuando falleció su primera
mujer ivana tram a mediados de julio
pero hoy ha tenido que enfrentarse a
esas preguntas a ese interrogatorio por
parte de la fiscal general de nueva york
en una semana que desde luego está
siendo muy complicada legalmente para el
exmandatario porque como saben a
principios de esta semana el fbi
registró su mansión en florida y este
viernes está previsto que la
organización tram y su jefe su director
de finanzas
ante los juzgados aquí en nueva york
porque piden que se desestimen que se
anulen unos cargos que hay contra ellos
a nivel fiscal en otra caso en otro
investigación esta vez penal que está
abierto y que está en manos de la fiscal
del distrito de manhattan